so the trailer for Spider-Man 2 came out
and it looks amazing so we are covering
the story that the game is largely based
off of which is Craven's last hunt one
of the most iconic stories that have
ever been written in the history of
Spider-Man so what this does here and
really a little bit of explanation to
offer before we get into this this picks
up with Spider-Man basically wearing his
black suit along with the death of Ned
Leeds so the first thing is that with
net leads he was a field reporter that
worked at The Daily Bugle and was if I
remember correctly at one point the
boyfriend of Betty Brandt the idea
behind this is that he'd been sent on a
task by J Jonah Jameson to track down
the Hobgoblin Roderick Kingsley Kingsley
ended up drugging uh Ned leads and then
more or less tricks the world into
thinking that Ned Leeds was the actual
hobgoblin when he wasn't and then in
turn Kingsley dumped the identity of
hobgoblin as Being Ned leads which led
to Ned leaves being killed by gangsters
Peter Parker discovered the body and
he's kind of been struggling ever since
the more important thing here is that
this story takes place before the events
of Amazing Spider-Man 258 1984 but it
takes place after Secret Wars so what
that means is that Peter Parker has what
we now call the Venom Suit but in
Spider-Man 258 is when he got rid of it
so he's still wearing this suit at this
point in time but it is an important
distinction because what he ends up
doing is basically catching up to these
gangsters kind of committing crimes and
doing the Spider-Man stuff and you know
facing off against them and trying to
defeat them and so on and so forth
what's important about this is that they
fear Spider-Man in this day and age as
opposed to the Peter Parker of years
past where they were more concerned
about him but they weren't really
fearful of him in the same way that they
would be afraid of like Batman and DC
Comics and that's one of the things that
I want you to notice about Craven's last
hunt one this story was written with a
much darker tone than a traditional
Spider-Man story and two the way the
criminals view Spider-Man is very
reminiscent of how criminals view Batman
and DC Comics they're afraid of him and
the reason for that is because during
the time when Peter Parker was in
possession version of the Venom symbiote
before he realized what it was in
Spider-Man 258 is that he won would lose
sleep at night because the Symbiote
would literally travel around in his
body at night and commit like various
superhero Antics but two when the Venom
symbiote was doing that he was very
Vigilant he like so people started to
see Spider-Man as more of a vigilante
than a traditional superhero so it's
cool in terms of how his character had
evolved up to this point in time that's
one of the reasons why Peter talks about
how he has a hard time sleeping because
some of this is due to the nightmares
that he has of Venom and the
symbiotinous influence and so on but
here in this part of the story it's more
like a it's more like a sixth sense
right he has this feeling that someone
out there is hunting him someone out
there is looking for him now a lot of
this goes into the nature of Craven the
Hunter and Craven is this guy I mean
this guy's Old Testament Man Fire
Brimstone wrath of God to quote uh Fast
and the Furious that's what this guy is
right he's old school he comes from the
days of like czarist Russia before the
fall of the Tsar Empire and the rise of
the Soviet Union really communist Russia
under Leon Trotsky and Vladimir Lenin so
this guy is super old hat but the bigger
thing here is he's very much a character
that's reminiscent of the book The Most
Dangerous Game where he does to a degree
find some measure of satisfaction in
hunting like dangerous animals but what
he actually prefers is to hunt the most
dangerous game possible whether it's
superheroes or just a person who's some
kind of crazy capable mercenary or
something like that whatever it is he
likes pushing himself to the limits the
reality of this is he's routinely been
defeated by Spider-Man over and over and
over again so much so that between the
fact that Spider-Man's defeated him in
years past combined with Craven's view
of himself and the darker nature of
Spider-Man in more recent years leads
Craven to believe that there's almost
something mythological about Spider-Man
that he's more than simply just a man I
wouldn't go as far as to use the phrase
Godlike but I would go as far as to say
that Craven sees him as on almost
something Supernatural in physical form
now what's ironic about this is that it
was actually Matthias kind of beating J
Michael cerzinski to the punch because
strazinski came along and he's the one
that introduced the idea of spider
totems the other the Peter Parker by
being Spider-Man tapped into a level of
power that was hitherto unknown to him
or seemingly anybody else all that stuff
came much much later but it is a cool
thing to kind of tie into right to kind
of keep in the back of your mind but
regardless Craven intends to hunt
Spider-Man and then basically kill him
and so what he does in preparation of
this is he immerses himself in spiders
and then starts eating them like he
literally starts eating spiders now he's
not doing this because he's insane I
mean he is he's kind of more or less
nuts because of the fact that he's been
defeated by Spider-Man what little
sanity had left basically went out the
window right I mean this guy this guy
belonged to the Looney Bin but the thing
about this is that in his mind is
actually him preparing for the fight
against Spider-Man one of the things
that he'll say later on when he's facing
Peter Parker is I have partaken of your
flesh I.E I have eaten spiders so now I
have basically taken over or at least
I'm able to tap into the power that you
have it's as much symbolic as it is
outright crazy because in a lot of ways
it really is Craven saying now I'm on
your level right that kind of a thing
kind of a whole tradition beginning the
the right of proving if you want to call
it that but the thing about this is that
as Peter's making his way to the city
Craven's dropped off by his forces now
that's one of the things that I do want
to point out about Craven the hunter
very rarely do you ever see him go into
a hunt with like a whole task force
because for Craven is considered
dishonorable for Craven like the Beauty
and the joy and the Hunt is that he can
do it on his own that he doesn't need
anybody else to pull that off they may
provide him with some resources but when
it comes down to the actual Act of
Craven hunting down a person and
attacking them it really is just his
thing right it's what he does by himself
and so one of the cool things that
happens here is he offers a sort of
inner monologue which is incredibly
important right he says for years the
spider has thwarted me mocked me
humiliated me in the beginning I was
naive I thought he was a man but he
couldn't possibly be a man no man could
do to Craven what the spider has no man
so black so inhuman so beautiful you
exist to test me don't you to taunt and
challenge me and I cannot rest until I
have proven myself until I have
destroyed you I cannot rest this is
incredibly valuable insight into the
mind of Craven because again he's very
much a man of tradition and honor within
the confines of his goal of tracking
people down and attacking them and
killing them but it shows that he views
Peter as being more than just a guy
running around in a Spider-Man suit he
sees him as almost mythological right
like this being that's been put on the
earth to test Craven the ultimate hunt
right the ultimate thing that he can
track down and kill it's just his own
personal Vendetta and that's one of the
cool things about Craven it's not about
levels of power right I mean if he was
like I'm going to track down the thing
that's really going to test me based on
power he'd be trying to kill the
molecule man Owen Reese right or like
the beyonder when he was on Earth or
maybe the Incredible Hulk but it's all
about symbolism it's all about what
Peter represents in the life of Craven
which is just this unattainable goal the
one that always eludes him and so as
Peter is making his way to the city he's
shot at by a dart now of course his
fighter sense allows him to basically
Dodge it but then he's hit the second
time and when that happens what ends up
going on is he starts to hallucinate
while he's hallucinating he's bobbing
and weaving trying to get away from
Craven but the whole time Craven's
offering this amazing monologue right he
says come to me my spider tonight I have
widened my Consciousness with herbs and
Roots tonight I have immersed myself in
your being eaten of your flesh of course
referring to the spiders and he says
tonight my mind has penetrated your
essence it feasts upon you like maggots
feasting upon a corpse come to me and
that's what's so cool is because Craven
despite just being a pretty capable guy
is able to subdue Spider-Man and almost
kind of taunt him but again the almost
mythological perception of Peter Parker
in the mind of Craven still comes home
to roost for Peter Parker the reason why
he's not able to easily overcome Craven
is really just stated in his words right
he talks about how his muscles are
getting stiff how he can hardly lift his
head he can't differentiate between
what's true and what's false the
Illusions he knows their Illusions but
the issue here is that he doesn't truly
realize what's actually going on with
Craven for example he hallucinates Joe
face but it's actually craving the
hunter who's there so it's one of the
things that makes this so incredibly
dangerous Craven tracking this guy down
ultimately Corners Spider-Man he shoots
him with a net literally catches him in
place and then in turn pulls out a rifle
and shoots Spider-Man on the spot just
executes him in plain sight and so
following that you have just this kind
of ceremonial moment where Raven has
Spider-Man buried on his own estate he
has Spider-Man buried at his own
location literally just buries this guy
covers him in dirt and so passes
Spider-Man but the question you have to
ask here is that if this is the first
issue what happens to the rest of the
four and I promise you it gets crazy
like it gets it's one of the most insane
stories that has ever been written in
the history of Marvel it's also arguably
the greatest Spider-Man story ever
written so with that being said we're
gonna bring this to an end let me know
in the comments if you guys want to see
more if you do we'll cover it next week
and I will catch you all later
peace